Hope everybody is ready.
Here we go. Let's roll the cameras.
We are 1571. So these
games are getting pretty
juicy. Our emphasis on the opening is
increasing,   and
presumably we're going to start
getting    a lot of main
lines.    So
this is where the brunt of my
opening instruction will come in.
We haven't gotten too many
Sicilians, uh, with the black,
so hopefully we get
something more mainstream. Marion
Gilea from Romania. Mainstream. Okay,
one, e three, but still, uh,
mulake. E Three is not that
uncommon, and it's worth
knowing   how to play against
it. It's worth knowing how to play against
it. So my recommendation
against one, D Four
is going to be the
GRUNFELD. And the great thing about playing
the GRUNFELD, I'm actually going to make a
move so that the game doesn't afford the
great thing about the Grunfield. Okay,
scratch everything that I'm about to say.
Clearly, our opponent is playing some sort
of troll opening   and
E three and D Three in and of itself
is not that bad
if white transitions
into a hippo set up. So the
hippo set up is where you feel and
keto both of your bishops, and then put the
knights on E Two and D Two. But some players
who really troll, they go like
C Three and B Three and A three. And
it still is very valuable
to know how to punish those setups,
because a lot of players, they either get
scared or they start
stumbling on their own moves. So in
this game, I'm going to offer
a sustainable
way to punish, uh,
whatever our opponent ends up playing. So
since our opponent has played D three, it no
longer makes as much sense for
us to stick with a
Gruenfelder King's Indian setup. Right? We
need to play in slightly
more principled fashion. Since our opponent
is giving us an opportunity to grab the
center, that's precisely what we are going
to do. So let's transition to
more principled chess and play
the move E five.
And
obviously, our next move is going to be D
Five, and our opponent continues to
play in a rather
dubious fashion. Let's grab
more of the center with D five. I've
had my fair share of hippo games
in previous speedruns. You can kind of look
around to find to find a few of
them.   And I've tried to be consistent in
terms of the setup that I offer
against these incredibly offbeat openings.
One element of the
setup that I prefer is
to refrain from putting the other
knight on C six. I actually really like a
setup where we play the move pawn to C six,
creating a little very solid pawn
chain, and then the night on B Eight
can maneuver itself to the
Kingside kind of Rule Lopez
style via, uh, D Seven and a
fate to G Six. And we have all the time in
the world to improve the position of our
pieces because white is playing so
unambitiously that we don't need to hurry
and rush to complete our
development. So let's start with a
move that solidifies our center
and takes the sting out of the move
knight F three. What move am I thinking
about here? And this move goes
really well. It
complements the move. C six. Well, if you're
a London player, you should be familiar with
this type of setup, where you put the bishop
on D six, or in the London, you put
your bishop on D three, and then you form
the pawn triangle with C three. And here
we're doing much the same thing. We're
defending the E five pawn with our bishop,
and we're defending the D five pawn with
our pawn. And then we get a super
compact, nicely
positioned center. Okay. So we can
castle kingside. We can place c
six. The order of operations here
is very unessential.
Right. It doesn't matter, because White is
not challenging our center.
So I think that
our best bet. Well, we're
going to start by castling. I don't see a
reason not to castle kingside. We're
definitely not going to castle queenside in
this type of position. That is, uh, way
too adventurous. We don't need to
rediscover the wheel here.
So   we're going to castle
kingside,    and
presumably, our opponent is going to play
bishop B Two. White is playing some sort
of a hippo
setup, but in the hippo, you normally
aren't advised to play the
move H three. Right. Because if White
now plays G Three, then White has created
an additional target on the
kingside by playing H
Three. So this really is not
a savory setup at all
by White. But, uh,
before we get to the crux of the
game, when we enter the middle game, it's
important to temper your expectations
when you're playing against these types of
setups. I can't tell you how many games I've
seen between beginners or
club players, where one side,
uh, employs a very offbeat setup
that you know is bad, and the other
side just goes directly for the throat
and ends up losing the game
because that kind of play backfires. It's
not like White is doing anything to lose the
game, and we need to refrain from the
temptation to go directly for White's
throat. We need to play this very patiently.
We need to get all our pieces out, and we
need to understand that breaking down these
types of setups takes time, and it's
impossible to do it in the opening.
Okay, so whiteplace g
three.   Now we're going to
continue with our
setup and play the move
C Six.   Now, if we want
to exert some pressure on the queen's side,
there is a very kind of typical idea
that we can employ at some point, not
necessarily immediately. We also could have
played that move here. And what I'm
talking about is the idea of advancing the
pawn down to A four and poking and prodding
at the queen side. Now, of course, if we
bring our pawn down to a four, white is
going to respond by playing V four.
But in that case, the
typical follow up is to chip away at
white's queenside by pushing the pond
to C five. And again, because the
center is closed, we have to
realize that moving the same piece twice,
moving the same pond twice
is not something that you should rule
out. Right. Because there is no
hurry here. Okay, so how do we
proceed? So I think a lot of
people would be tempted to develop this
bishop to e six
or to F five. But we're actually going to
leave this bishop on C eight for the time
being. The reason I don't like
bishop f five is because you're
walking right into g four
kingside expansion or you're walking into
a potential e three, e four, bishop e six is
a better move, but
I don't really see the reason for
us developing. Uh, and another specific
thing I don't like about bishop e six is
that after night f three knight B
to D seven, white has the rather annoying
move night g five. And we certainly don't
want to give our LightSquared bishop away.
Why don't we want to give our LightSquared
bishop away? Because if you think about the
middle game, white is very likely to castle
kingside. And one of our typical plans is
going to be to put pressure on the h three
plum. So don't be
afraid to leave one of your pieces on
its initial square. How should we
proceed? I think we should continue
developing with knight B to D seven. And
then we are going to reposition the knight
to g six by playing rookie
eight, which is a good move in and of
itself. Right. This move is not going to
hurt. We're reinforcing the e five pawn.
This is called over protection.
And now we are going
to guide our knight
over to F eight and then toward
g six.
Okay. Queeny two. But that
changes a lot. I was obviously
expecting White to play 92.
What queeny two signals to
me is that our opponent is flirting
with the idea of castle and
queenside. And that is a
suicidal plan. But it's not
immediately obvious that castle and
queenside   is losing
here. Right. And if why does
castle queenside?
The checkmate is not going to play
itself. We need to position ourselves
in such a way that if
white castles queenside on the next
move, we are going to be ready to
jump right into the attack. And I've
already pointed out the main attacking
method on the queen side, which is
especially good if there is a king on that
side of the board. What am I talking about?
What should we play? We're going to play a
move that basically tells our opponent,
don't shoot dare castle
queenside. Don't shoot dare castle
queenside. Because I'm going to be ready to
make mincemeat out of you. A five. Very
good. And if our opponent goes queenside,
if he dares, then we play a
four, B four, and C five, and
we blast the queenside open. I'll show
that after the game. Instead, our opponent
plays e four. Okay? So e
four is a totally reasonable
move,    and we are going
to continue with
our initial plan, of course,
and get this knight over
to G six. And you might wonder what the
knight is doing on G six, especially because
it seems to be restricted heavily by
the pawn on G three. But, uh,
what you have to remember is that
ultimately we are going to go after
White's king no matter which
way the king castles, right? So just
assembling a piece on the king side
is a good idea in and of itself. The other
thing that I like about the move nine G six,
is that the pawn at E five is very nicely
protected by a lot of our pieces. And
if you think about it, white's got quite a
few pieces staring at e five as well. So
whatever we do, I think it's quite
important for us to keep the E five
pawn nicely protected. And
so Nike E six makes sense,
both from an attacking perspective
and from a more defensive perspective
as well. And those types of moves are always
really good.   What if white doesn't? Castle
well, we'll cross that bridge if we get
there, I think White will. Castle I'm
expecting our opponent to play night GF
three. We will accelerate our pace a little
bit. And I have a very interesting
idea in response to night F three that we
could try.     We'll, uh,
wait for our opponents to play this
move.    Yeah. Of course, we
could have also tried the move 96, but
after night F three,
we're not able to squeeze our knight into D
four. And what I don't like about the
knight on E six is that it
blocks both the rook and the light squared
bishop. So that night on E six would really
get on the nerves of our
other pieces. We want each piece to
be out of the way of the other pieces.
Okay, so some of you may
be wondering why I'm not
exchanging the pawn on E four, and I don't
see a reason why we should exchange.
Exchanging helps White a lot more than it
helps black, because it creates for the D
two knight, a stronghold on C four,
and it opens up the D file. And who stands
to benefit from that open D file? Well, it's
definitely White, because White is ready to
get a rook to D one, and then our queen on
D eight is going to end up
under some serious fire. We're going to have
to move our queen away, and then the
knight's going to jump into C four. So we're
letting White unfurl his pieces and expand
the pawn on D five is a very
important cog in the machine because it's
restricting the knight on D two, and we're
never afraid of White
exchanging on D five. That just yields
total control of the center to us. Queen f
one. Our opponent not really playing
too actively here, and
I really think the time
has come for us to start punishing this. I
think the time has come for us
to show our opponent that this
kind of play is not acceptable.
Now, how are we going to do that? Well, a
lot of you are probably contemplating the
idea of pushing the pawn down to
H four, and that's a very
legitimate idea. I actually
was considering to play H
five, but in response to knight
F three, I think here we have a much more
readily available attacking option,
an option that I've already pointed out, and
I think now is the perfect time to put this
into effect, to carry this out.
When I say we want to punish
White for this type of play, what do I
really mean? What does it mean to punish
in the context of chess? Well, normally what
that means is we have to open up the
position. Unless we open up
either the center or one side of the
board, we're never going to be able
to actually   punish
White for playing passively. If the position
remains closed, white can do whatever the
hell he wants. He can go King E two for all
we care. Right. So we have to find a
way to open up some avenues of
infiltration, and we have a really good way
of doing that. Right. We already played A
five, so let's carry out the
idea I mentioned earlier. With A
four, we are inducing
B four, and if I doesn't play before then,
we take on B three, and we open up the A
file. Why is it good to open up the
A file? Well, then we can attack A three,
but that ship has sailed. And now we play
C Five, and we blast open the entire
position.
White has been very naughty,
and now White has no
choice but in one way or
another to accept the
opening of the position. White cannot
keep things completely closed here. He
plays, he takes D five. I don't think that's
a very good move. What is our response to
that move? Uh, have we blundered upon?
Have we blundered upon? Have
we given up our main center pawn? No, we
don't really care about positional
considerations anymore. All we really care
about now is opening up the position as
much as we can. And
at that point, the position is largely going
to play itself. What do we do now? Well,
obviously, we take on before, and we need to
reassess the situation. Right. There have
been a lot of trades. The position has
transformed. What's going on? Well,
on the surface, we have given up a
center pawn for a corner pawn.
But those kinds of general
considerations could not matter less because
we're about to checkmate our opponent. All
right? Now we need to be calm here, and
we need to go for simplicity
over something fancy. Perhaps some of you
are attracted to the move A three, but
it doesn't work. Calculate C takes
B four, a takes B two, rook
takes rook. And notice that the night on D
two is covering the promotion square. So we
do need to move our bishop. Or
do we we have a sacrifice here that we
should consider. There's the very
interesting move. Knight takes D five
straight away.   And if White
accepts the bishop, then we take back
with our knight and we have, uh, a gazillion
threats in that position. We're threatening
to take on D three with another fork. We're
threatening a fork on C two.
So    in a
blitz game, I would take on D
five without a second thought. Also, what
I want you to see is that if White
plays bishop takes D five,
very importantly, after queen takes D five,
the rook in the corner is hanging.
Otherwise, uh,    White would have simply
taken the bishop. But this is the speed
run, and I do want to
emphasize simplicity and straightforwardness
in the speed run. So
I'm also very
tempted to just drop the bishop back to C
five because the pawn on D
five, well, I guess it can be
defended. White can play the move C four,
but then we can bring our queen out to B six
and we can attack F two. So I'm really torn.
I'm kind of conflicted here, to be totally
honest. Let me actually take a little bit of
time to think about this. I'm going to try
to calculate knight takes D five and make
sure that it's actually good.
So
takes knight takes B
four.     White can play
the move rook to a three. Then we have a
fork on C two.   It does
look    very
good. Now let's compare that to bishop C
five. Bishop C five, C
four.    Maybe we can
push the pawn up to a three. Oh, what the
hell? Let's do it. Knight takes d five.
Let's have some fun.
Let's have a little bit of fun.
Yeah. I just feel
like if you look at White's King, white
is not even close to castling.
The final
consideration here for me is the fact
that White is nowhere
near castling. And as long as the White King
remains in the center, I just
don't  believe that White can hold this
position together. Another thing to remember
okay, and we have the immediate payoff. This
is obviously an impulsive
panicky move. I was going to say
that. Really? Players under 2000 tend to
panic in these types of situations, and they
tend to panic very, very quickly. So
you often don't need to wait very long
for a terrible move to
arrive at the seat.   So what
do we do? Why is king E two a
terrible move? Well, it's a terrible
move because he's blundering the pawn
on D three with
check,    and I don't see a
reason for us not to take it.
Now, the game is not
over because, well, it's
over. If White drops the king back
to D one, then we give
h well, we give a check on C two,
obviously, and we win the bishop back, and
then the game is totally over. If White had
gone king E one, we would have had to
demonstrate a little bit more finesse in
order to finish the game off. And I'll show
you what I would have done after the game.
It's a little bit anticlimactic,
but still, let's try to be accurate until
the end of the game. This is an instructive
moment. This is an instructive moment
because I think the majority of people would
grab the bishop without a second thought.
But you have to remember that when you've
got an attack of this magnitude,
you really should be looking for
checkmate. You really should not be
prioritizing material
unless it's a queen. Right. If you
can win a queen or you can win a
rook, that's one thing, but a minor
piece, probably. We should look for
something a little bit more ambitious. So
let's see if we can find a forced mate.
I'm actually thinking about
something,    but it doesn't
seem too clean. I'm sure it's
winning. So I think
the low hanging fruit here is the idea of
pinning well, of skewering the
queen. Right? So the first thing that I see
when I look at this position is the fact
that the king and the queen are aligned. So
that gets me thinking about the prospect of
moving the bishop onto
either F uh five or even to D seven, or even
to move B six.   But
anywhere on this diagonal would skewer the
king. But let's try to find the most
accurate square because,
well, I like the look of
Bishop D seven. I really
like the look of bishop D seven
because White cannot prevent the
bishop from moving on to onto B
five.   So I
do not see a defense   in response to
Bishop D seven. Of course, bishop F five
I think is equally good. I
think Bishop F five is equally good.
I don't think there is a big difference.
Yeah, we could also have played rook D
eight. And I point this out almost every
single time we have a position
that's this overwhelming.
You might be sitting there thinking, why
didn't I play this move or that move
or the other move? Chances
are that move is also winning.
There isn't just one winning option
in these types of positions. There's usually
going to be six or seven moves that all win
the game. Queen C one gets rid of the
skewer. But Bishop B five is
still totally devastating because if the
king drops back to e one, there is obviously
a fork on D three, followed by
checkmate. And if the king goes fourth,
king E three, queen D three is mate, and
king F three is mate in two,
that I will let you find.
What is the fastest path to checkmate?
It's a nice little sequence. It's
easy.     Now, remember, if
we can get the king to e three,
then queen back to D three is
mate. So it's very easy. You just need
to shepherd the king to the right
square. You do that with the retreating
move, queen, uh, F five. And after king E
three, queen D three is
checkmate. And our opponent played way too
fast and way too sloppily. So
it's a slightly anti climactic game.
I apologize for that. But
I still think there's instructive
value to be squeezed.
Resigns. Yeah. King E three, queen
E three is checkmate.
And we're close to
1600 with that win. Thank you.
Danish chestnut for the tier one.
Yeah. So I'm a little bit
disappointed at the opening that we got,
because if you are a hippo
player, the best way to actually
play the hippo is to start by
fiancetoing the bishops. So if you see
Grandmasters play the hippo, and that does
happen normally in Hikaru, for example,
likes to play the hippo against computers
because the position is very closed and
engines can sometimes struggle with that
kind of thing. I think you play the hippo
against Mittens, for example. So B
three is the best way to reach a
hippo setup. And for
example, after E five, Fisher B two,
night C six, you play
G, fisher
G two, you start by Fion ghettoing. And
after a night F six, you play
E, then 92 and
92. And the hippo is not actually such
a bad opening.  Uh,
it's not easy to
show a concrete advantage against
it. But I don't
recommend it, really, for anybody under
Grandmaster level because it hits on all the
wrong things. You're not practicing your
opening fundamentals. You're just
making the same crappy moves
over and over again, and it's just not
fun. White is essentially kind of sitting
around and waiting
for black to strike, hoping that black
strikes prematurely or in the wrong way. So
I won't analyze the hippo
from white's perspective. I don't
recommend it at all.   So let's go back to
the game. E three, knight F
63. So hopefully it makes
sense why I transitioned
to the move E five. If
our opponent had played something more
conventional, something like D three
or D four, then we would
have played a GRUNFELD setup
because this is essentially just a
opening.
You might wonder whether E five
is the best move here. E five is
fine, but this allows white to
transition into the English opening with C
four and also the reverse
French is not bad for white. I don't think
E five is the best move. I think D
five is a very, very
legit move here as well. But
again, White can transition into the Kali
system by playing D four. So I think Knight
F six is probably the best move
objectively.
So d three e five.
A.
Remember that anytime White plays before
in such positions, you almost always respond
with a classic move, A five.   And
this already induces
serious weaknesses on the Queen side.
If White takes, then White is left with
a terrible isolated corner
pawn. And if White plays B
five,   then we have a couple
of options. We can drive the pawn to A
four, isolating the B five
pawn even further, or we can
push the pawn up to C six,
essentially using the pawn on B five
to get our pieces out. And again, this type
of structure with an isolated pawn on A
three is terrible for White. So do not be
afraid of the move b four. You don't always
have to play A five yourself.
H three. Bishop d
six. B three.
We Castle. White
plays G three,
and my favorite set up is to push
the pawn up to C six. And the kind of
positional underpinning of this move is very
simple. We want the Bishop to be biting on
granite when it fenkettos to G two.
I like this move a lot more
than night C six.
I think the set up with Ponta C
six is really, really watertight. It's
compact, and it's easy to play.
So White responds with
Bishop B two, and we get the night
out.
Again, remember, that piece placement is
temporary, so you should not rule
out a move like this because it blocks the
Bishop. This is your piece, and you can
choose to move it again. So blocking the
Bishop is purely temporary. It's
Frankfurt Airport, right? The final
destination for the night is going to be G
six.     What
about C five instead of C six?
A couple of people are asking. So that's an
alternative setup. C five
is an alternative setup which
emphasizes spatial
control. But that's actually the reason
I don't like it as much. The
problem is that after Bishop G two,
obviously the pawn on D five is a little bit
weaker, uh, than it would be if our pawn is
on C six. Right? And second of
all, my recommendation with
White is one E four,
and essentially, this is like a
reverse King's Indian setup. So
this resembles a
opening with colors reversed. But
I'm trying to play against
offbeat openings in the spirit of a one E
four player. Does that kind of make sense?
If you think about it, what is the
King's Indian? Well, the King's Indian and
the Kings Indian, white gets pawns on
E,
but in the perk, in the perk,
which is like the equivalent of the Kings
Indian against one E four, you don't
get that pond on C four. So the
distinguishing factor between a lot
of D four openings and a lot of e four
openings is that the C pawn
remains on C two in most e four
openings. So it's not all
about   the amount of
pawns that you have in the center. It's also
about the quality of your central
control. Now, how is the game likely to
unfold if you play C five? Oh, White is
going to go Bishop G two, black goes 96.
And of course, black is better. Right?
This is totally legitimate setup. You can
put your bishop on E six, and your center
is still very well defended.
I'm belaboring the point here.
By and large, c five is just an
alternate setup.  So we
decided on C six, knight
BD seven, rookie eight, knight
D two, knight F eight. And so far, White
is doing everything correctly. And here our
opponent starts going completely off the
rails. Queeny two is a very strange move,
but still not that bad. Still not
that bad. As long as White would have
followed it up by
actually getting this knight out to f
three. The conventional way to play
this, of course, is 92. This completes the
hippo setup. Then we would have played
Nike six, and likely White would
have Castled Kingside. Now,
what are the available plans here for
black? Well, you can play both on the
kingside and on the queen side. You
absolutely can still play the move H five.
And if you want to play h
five, it might actually make sense.
No, I think ni G six castles, and h five
makes a lot of sense. And you can just chill
on h five. Uh, you don't have to rush the
move h four because the pawn on h
five is perfectly well protected by the
knight. It's unattackable. And if
White plays H four, then White
creates a massive hole on G four
that you can stick a bishop in. And
let's not even talk about the effect of the
move F three. So how much is Black better in
these positions? I would say
objectively, it's like 0.7.8 according
to the computer. So you're not winning
number one and number two.
You have to squeeze these positions for a
very long time. You're not going to win the
game in two moves. So, for instance, I
would maybe play h five. Let's say that
white does nothing. Let's say that white
plays a random move queen C one.
Then I would bring the Bishop out to e
six. I would also very seriously
consider the prospect of playing
h engine
confirms this. You can actually sack on
G four in a lot of these positions. We had a
speedrun game that I won in a
very similar way. In this position,
knight takes G four is already very, very
strong,   because if you look at this
position, you have two pawns for the piece.
White's pieces are tremendously passive. H
three is coming in, and at some
point you could push e four to open up. The
dark squared bishop. So black's attacking
potential here is massive. It's already
minus three. According to the engine.
White plays f
three. You simply drop the bishop back to
d seven,   and white's
position is indefensible. Here the queen's
coming out to g five, the pawns moving
to h three. Everybody in the chat
intuitively should understand why
this position is terrible for white, even
without calculating any
variations.    Thank you, jaber,
for the rate. Can white go f four?
Asks Maculangelo.
F four, you take it. And
the night on e two is undefended. So the
funny thing is, the random move that I
chose   is actually
detrimental to white's position because it
leaves the knight on e two unprotected.
Maybe white should play a move like king h
one. And here I would develop the bishop to
e six. Then I would play queen d
seven and force the king up to h
two,    where it is x
rayed by the dark squared bishop. And
one thing that could happen is after queen d
seven, king h two, what move
is once again very, very
strong? Who can tell me, uh, how
black should squeeze the most out of the
position? Yeah, again, h
four. And after g four,
apart from the
sacrifice on g four, which is still very
interesting, you can consider the move e
four. Check. And you can consider the very
typical plan of moving the
knight off of f six and
blasting open the kingside by pushing the
pawn up to f five. And to
that you might ask, well, am I not
worried about weakening my own
king? And the answer is no, because of
how passive white is. White does not have
the firepower to exploit
the weakening of black's black's king,
but the vice versa statement is
untrue. Our pieces are positioned
perfectly to attack white's king.
If you don't want to play on
the kingside, you can also play on the
queenside. The exact mirror
image of the kingside plan
is also effective, which is what we did in
the game. You can play the move a five,
and then at some point, you can play the
classic idea a four, b four, and
c five. What is the effect of this
idea? And I wouldn't necessarily do it
here, because here you have allowed white to
play d four. Here you have allowed white to
play the very nasty move d four. And as a
consequence, white establishes a very strong
night on this square. But what I'm talking
about is, in more general terms, what are
the available ideas? Assuming
that this is not possible, you have isolated
the a three pawn, and on the next move, you
could attack it by building a battery,
forcing the rook back to a one, and
at some point, you could bring your BP on up
the board and create a past pawn on a
four.   Okay, so I'm just trying to give you
I'm trying to brainstorm some ideas to show
you that just because the position is closed
does not mean you just have to shuffle
your pieces for 50 moves. There are specific
things that you can do, and most of them
involve reopening at one side of the
board.    Right. And the
reason this is such a bad opening
for newer players or
intermediate players is that White has no
activity. If you're a white hippo
player, you have to be able to just
shuffle your pieces, essentially add
infinitum, and that's not what
you want to do to build
skill.  And that's why it
boggles my mind at how many players
just decide on a setup like
this. It's masochistic.
Okay? So unless there are any questions,
we're going to move to the game. I could
talk about this in far more depth, but I
don't want to overwhelm you with ideas.
Queeny two.   We play
a five, right? Preemptively pushing
our pawn up and
discouraging White from castling queenside.
What would have happened if White Castles
queenside? Well, now we definitely play A
four, and we definitely play C
five.   And
perhaps in this position, white could play
B five. But here, I think we have a very
powerful move. How do we
prevent White from linking up
his pawns with C four? Who can tell me? And
this is a move which may seem anti
positional. You're giving up some squares,
but you're essentially isolating the B
five pawn, not C four. Come on. C
4d takes C four. Just blunders upon.
We want to play the move D
four, right? And yes, we're opening up
the Bishop. And, yes, we're giving up the C
four, a square. But we are taking the sting
out of the move C four, because here we take
on passant. And then we victimize
the B five pawn with Bishop to D seven. And
once this pawn drops, White's, king is
just going to be in shambles.
So that would be one idea, but we don't have
to rush, right? We don't have to rush
with A four. And we can also
start by playing the move queen E seven. In
fact, we probably should do this, forcing
White into making this incredibly passive
move. And now A four
looks a whole of a lot better. A. Four, b,
four, c, five. And again, the
same thing
b. On the next move,
we go Bishop. D. Seven takes B 05:00 A.m.. I
worried about losing the B seven pawn. I
want to lose that pawn to open up the B
five. White has nothing going on. The
kingside this position is losing.
Okay,
now,   John
Frath suggests the
idea of, uh, playing queen E seven.
Queen E seven is a great move, and it also
prevents White from castling because he
drops a three. But I actually wanted to
encourage White to cast like, I wanted to
play a move that sort of provokes White into
castling because it's such a big mistake.
And we know that a five is a helpful
move regardless. Those are the types
of moves you want to play. You want to play
moves that you're not going to regret even
if your opponent does not go along with kind
of the main idea of the move, if that makes
sense. Right. So a move that I would not
want to play is b five, because b five is
a pretty weakening move. And if
white does not castle queenside, it's kind
of hard to justify this. A five is
a far less positionally committal move, if
that makes sense. Okay, so our opponent
responds with a four, which is a good move.
Nike six. And here, I think
queen f one is perhaps the decisive mistake.
I think after a four, white's
position is borderline lost.
What should white have done? Well,
obviously, white should have brought the
night out to f three. And in
response to that, I, uh, had a couple of
ideas. I think the most
noncommittal move is actually to play bishop
d seven.   Why not bishop e six?
Because we want to maintain the x ray
between the rook and the queen. Bishop d
seven, white castles.
Okay. The engine proposes
to play slowly with a move like h six, which
I like, just making some lift, and the
game goes on again. It's the same. We play
in the same spirit  that we would
play if the knight was on e two. We squeeze,
we make improvements. We can play a move
like queen c seven, reinforcing the pawn.
And largely, white's
position is miserable. Not
because black has a specific idea that makes
it miserable, but just because white has no
active plan. White's pieces are so cramped
and so passive. This is like a king's Indian
attack, but down like
610 p. Another thing I would
consider is to start with queen c eight
and force the king up and then go queen c
seven, because later on, you might be
thankful that there is an x ray going on.
And still the idea of h five ah, h four,
uh,   is very much feasible
for black.    Okay. And
I still like the idea of going a four and c
five at some point.    So one
of the key takeaways from this game
is that in these closed center
positions, you have to be really patient.
You have to be ready to play five or six
moves that slowly improve your position. But
you also have to be on alert for tactics.
Right. You can't fall asleep because you
never know when the blunder could come.
How would I keep improving here? Well,
I've just shown a lot of different
ideas. Let's say that white
literally goes back to g one.
Well, I would already
consider the move a four,
and after b four,
i, uh, would have to calculate the move c
five. This is a very committal option. The
engine doesn't like it. Now, analyzing with
an engine in such positions can be
quite dangerous, because, as you guys know,
engines are not always very good in
closed center positions. They often
essentially suggest a strategy
of shuffling your pieces back and forth. So
sometimes you really have to prod
the engine to look at more concrete lines.
For instance, the engine does recommend
the move B five, which
is interesting. Expanding on the queen
side, let's say that White continues going
back and forth. Now the engine proposes the
move rook eight. D eight, which is
reasonable. Okay, let's say
White continues to go back and forth.
Now queen B
seven,     and
okay. And a four. So the engine does
spot the idea of going A four and C
five.    Yeah. And now,
apparently, queen A seven.
And then C five is very strong
because in the event of the exchange,
you've got a very strong
battery against the F two square. So I think
you can kind of see,   uh, in
what direction I would take this type of
position. Right. You play patiently, and
then you find the best opportunity to reopen
the game.   Okay, enough on
this position. Let's have a look at the
game continuation. Queen f uh, one.
A four, b four. C five.
And I explained this pretty deeply during
the game, so I won't go over the logic
again. I think White's last chance to
stay alive was probably to play
B five.   And once
again, this is a recurring
idea. How should black continue in this
position? Who can tell me?   Actually,
the engine proposes C four just blasting the
center open. But if we want to play this,
uh, in a human way, we
play D four. We close down the
center, and we do it in order
to pick off this B five. Pawn
92. And the best way to do it is actually
queen to A five
because the knight is also pinned. White's
position is so miserable
here.    Or you could play
C four    DC.
And now just knight takes C four.
Just smash through the center.
And this position also looks terrible for
White. You can give a check on a five. I
mean, just look at this piece
of crap on the queen side. This. Clunker c
three. Bishop B six. Rook c eight is coming.
We're going to win this pawn. Now White is
losing.  So I
think the position is beyond repair already
after C five. But our
opponent makes it worse. E takes D five is
probably also a mistake.
And I'm very curious what the
engine thinks of the move. Knight takes
d five.     The
engine likes it. Yeah. Knight takes D five
is the best move.
Also very good.
Would have just been to drop the bishop
back. Also very good. And after C
four, we just put the bishop back on B
four in order to pin the knight.
And who can tell me, after night GF
three, what is the most straightforward
winning move for Black? This should be
absolutely automatic. Your hand should be
reaching for this move the moment White
plays knight F three. Because you know what
the strategy is. E four. Just blast it
open.   D e 494.
King d one. A three. Play on
the flank.  Bishop d four. And
now the simplest is just to
develop the bishop, let's say to F five.
Do not be afraid. Uh, a takeaway from
the previous game. To play
normal developing moves in the midst of an
attack. Not every move needs to be a
sacrifice or needs to threaten.
Checkmate. Just bring your pieces
out and then go queen D seven and queen A
four, check. Encircle the king and
checkmate it. So people
really struggle with moves like
bishop C eight to, uh, F five in the midst
of an attack. But you haven't sacrificed
anything, so you're allowed to play a move
that's on the slower side. Knight c three
check. Of course, is also quite
good. Black is completely winning.
No, but you're not pausing. Bishop f Five is
an attacking move. But not all
attacking moves are created equal. You have
different categories of attacking moves.
Some are sacrifices. Make a
move to blast open the center. But there are
other attacking moves that just bring a
piece into the attacker, into the game.
Bishop F.
What happens here? I think we
ignore. I think we
play I'm not using the engine
here.   Okay. At this point, I would already
start calculating concretely
and I would consider the move
queen D seven,
GF. Uh,  let's calculate queen A
four, check. And we find the checkmate here.
King c one.   And, you know, I
think it's time for another slow move.
Okay, let's check the engine. I'm
curious,   and I was right.
The move Ni G six to F four is minus twelve.
Calling
reinforcements, you're aiming for E two,
which is a checkmating square. White
is totally busted.
Totally busted.
Um, white is no moves. Just look at
the king and look at white's pieces.
For instance, knight takes E four, rook
takes E four. Let's say white plays
bishop E three.   We
squeeze the queen into B three and we attack
C four. These are pretty simple
moves.   You just need to
get experience in attacking chess to find
them smoothly.   In any
case, this is completely one
sided. So Bishop F eight was
a totally viable alternative. The
evaluation here is minus five.
We decided on the sacrifice, and it really
is a shame that our opponent just
folded over so quickly. After king E
two, queen D three, the game is over. I
will just show one more
line after king D one. Queen
c two. The game ends
immediately.   If White had gone. King
E One this actually leads to an
instructive moment because I think
most people would get very excited at the
prospect of Ni C two. You're probably
thinking that right now, but what you cannot
do is just say, oh, I see an
exchange. Let's take and then take and
take. Because remember, you've
sacrificed a piece, so black is
better here, of course, probably even
winning. But this gives up a
lion's share of your advantage. Why would
you trade queens here? That defeats the
whole purpose. So what
you have to see here is that queen
takes d three is actually
not a threat, because in that case,
we take on d three, and we win an entire
bishop back. So can you
propose a move that essentially
encourages white to trade on
d three?   It's a
zen move,   and it's a
very powerful move. A three is great.
That's one option.   What about
doing it with a piece?     Rook to d eight.
Beautiful. Rook e eight to d eight. You
deserve some subs.    This
attacks the knight. Now, if
white stubbornly
defends the knight, then what you have
to see is that it's not the queen that
belongs on d three. It's the knight. So we
go queen c two, and we squeeze the knight
into d three with devastating effect.
White basically has to take.
Now we play knight takes d three. We play
knight takes b two, and it's totally
winning. We've got two extra pawns. We've
got three extra pawns. The king on e
two is in shambles. And this idea
of bishop d seven to b five is going to be
further devastating to the white
king.   Okay? Does that kind of make
sense?    Hope it makes
sense. So our opponent just folds over and
dies. And bishop d seven is just
a nice final finesse
to get the bishop to b five with
decisive effect.
Any other
questions? Obviously, the checkmate here is
to go back to f five and force the
king to move to e three, and
then the queen moves into d three with
mate.   Okay, we've got
a couple of questions. Knight f four,
check. Instead of queen takes d three,
check. Yes, that was also winning. And I did
see that move. We could start with the
move night. F four, check. I just thought
this was a little bit too advanced for the
speedrun. Basically, the idea
is that after g takes f four, now you
play queen takes d three. Check. And
what is the purpose of sacrificing on f
four? It is to reopen the e file at your
convenience.    But this should make
sense to everybody. And the game is over.
King d one, queen c two is literally
checkmate. And if flight plays
92, then oh, uh,
the top engine move is
sexy.   This is a sexy move. And
I will give you an exact parallel for
this move. Let's take a little
detour. And let me tell you a story.
Let me tell you a
story.   So
rewind the clock back to,
uh, an olympiad that took place in
the city of Gothenburg, Sweden,
uh, in the year
1955.
So, obviously,
uh, in that
era, the USSR team was
totally dominant. They basically won every
Olympiad. So USSR. Is
playing Argentina. And
Argentina actually had a very strong team.
They had Miguel Nydorf. They
had a guy named Oscar Pawno
who was an opening specialist.
Herman Pilnick International. Uh,   master.
And they had a StrongBoard four. So this was
not a walkover for Team   Soviet, uh,
Union.
So   essentially,
the USSR had all one E
four players. Jeff uh,   M. Geller, Paul
Carris,  uh, everybody
on that team was
essentially exclusively an E four
player. So Team Argentina gets
together   in PA's hotel
room and they decide to
do something very interesting. They all
decide to play the same opening.  They
decide that they're going to prepare this
opening very extensively.
And they're going to show Team
USSR that they are not
afraid,  uh, of a theoretical
struggle, that they believe in their
preparation. And because Miguel Nydorf
was on Team Argentina, he was
the team captain. And he says, we're playing
what I like. We're playing the
Nidorf. So they all agree we're playing
the Nidorf.    So
they played the Nidarf, and
they knew they looked up
Geller's games. Yep. And Geller
was the elder statesman
of the Russia team. So people were going to
play what Geller plays. And Geller was a
Bishop G five player.
So, to the
elation of Team
Argentina, they play Nidarf on all
boards,  and Russia responds
with Bishop G five on all boards, going
right into Argentina's preparation.
And because this was 1955,
the theory of the Nidorf
was still in its kind of
initial stages. And so
Argentina came up with a line that obviously
nowadays is considered extremely well
analyzed. It's not, um,  a
surprise at all, but back then, it was
virtually a novelty.
And it goes bishop E seven,
queen F three.
On two of the boards. On two of the
boards, obviously,   H
six.    Bishop
H
takes G five.    And in this
position, they had prepared the line
knight F six to D seven.
I don't know if they called it the night or
effect then. I don't think so. So this has,
uh, since then been known as the Gothenburg
variation because of where it was
played. But amazingly
FM. Geller, years ago had
analyzed this line,
and he had come up
with essentially a
reputation.  And the reputation goes
as follows does anybody know
how USSR. Refuted this line?
And this is often referred to as the
Argentinian tragedy.
Knight takes E six is
correct. And the crazy thing is, since
then, engines have found a way to revive the
line. So the best move, according to modern
engines, the actual reputation is queen
F three to H five.   But back
then, Geller shocked pawno with knight
takes E six. F takes C
six. Queen h five. Checking f eight. Now,
Argentina had analyzed this position
and concluded that
the peace sacrifice is unsound. Why
did they conclude that the peace sacrifice
was unsound? Because here's the
thing. What does White want in this
position? Well, obviously, White wants to
put a rook on f one. So if you allow white
to put a rook on f one or to castle, the
game is over.   Because
king g seven, queen f seven is checkmate.
Right,   but here's the
thing. Argentina was expecting
the move bishop e two or the move bishop
c four. But this is just too slow. And
black is able to escape
with the move 95.
And the point of 95 is that it covers
the f uh, seven square.   And after white
castles, black safely plays
king g seven.   The square
on f seven is protected.
And all that white can
try   is to drop the bishop
back to g three.
Okay, what is the purpose of
bishop g three? Well, white wants to
eliminate the knight on e five and deliver
checkmate on f seven, but
no harm, no foul. Black displays knight
c six. And we're fine because
the knights defend each other and the king
is perfectly safe. G takes h six, check work
h six leads absolutely
nowhere.    But to the
absolute shock of team
Argentina. On both boards where
the argentinians played this line,
both soviet players
responded with the same crazy
move.    If you've
understood and paid attention to the line I
just showed, you should be already able
to come up with that move. Bishop f
one to b five.
Bishop f one to b
five.     And the point
of course,
is that after king g seven or, sorry,
after a takes b five, it's mate. And we know
how after king g seven,
the uh,  move is
to castle.  And after
95, bishop h four to g
three, the point of the move
is revealed. The knight can't get
out to c six or d seven. It can, but you're
just going to capture it. And then you're
going to capture on e five and checkmate the
king on f seven. And there is very little
else that black can do in this position.
Here's the reason
why. If black tries work f
eight, then white wins with
queen takes h six and g
six.    If black tries
queen g eight. Then white
wins with a beautiful idea,
takes, takes. And now a move
that's going to knock your socks off.
Bishop b five to e
eight,
threatening rook f
seven, forcing the queen to e eight.
And now the deflection with g takes h
six. You can't take with the rook, because
you get mated on e eight or sorry, you lose
your queen. If you step back, you lose your
queen. And if you step to the
side, you get check mated with rook f
seven.     So that's the
reason you can't play queen g eight.
How else can you try to defend f seven?
Well, there's only uh, one other move,
and that's 95 to g six.
But now another beautiful tactic, g h six,
rook h six. And who can find the follow up?
Who can find the follow up.
And um, we're following the game
geller against Pono,
or no, we're not following. I'll show you
what pano played. I'll show you what
pawno played.
Rook f seven. Beautiful.
And Queen takes h six. A takes b
five.   Check
here, forced
check   back. And we just
take everything. I mean, just look at
black's position.   So in the actual
Geller pawno game, oscar
pawno   played, uh,   the
immediate 95.
Geller played bishop g three.
And here, pawno is already
totally lost because if black goes king G
seven,   this isn't even
the worst version of the line we
just analyzed. Of course, black should
go king g seven first, but he was so shell
shocked that he played 95 1st.
Here, white can eliminate the knight first
and castle,   and
this eliminates the option of knight g
six. So here, white wins on the spot.
So Oscar pawno played, uh,
bishop takes g five and lost
after castles, king E seven. And, of
course, bishop takes E five. And the game is
over because, uh,
it is queen b six. Check
was the game. King h one
de, and Geller hunts the
king down. Check
here. Check. And pawner
resigned in three moves. He has
to give up his queen in order to avoid
getting checkmated. And the other game
ended in very similar fashion.
So that's the story. That's the
Gothenburg tragedy. Why did I tell
this story? Hopefully, you were sufficiently
entertained, but people on YouTube might be
wondering why. What made me think of that
story? Well, what made me think of that
story is the engine's top recommendation
in our game.
So in my game, let's
flip the board again     after,
uh, knight F four check, which I
was analyzing. Queen takes D.
Three. Check. King E one, he takes
f four. Check. 92. The top
engine recommendation is a very similar
mechanism. It's. Bishop to g
four. And the idea is to play
this move with tempo and force white to
spend the tempo so that you can get
the rook into d eight without allowing white
to make an additional defending move.
If rook D 192 is Smothered
mate, if the knight moves, 92 is still
checkmate.   And if white tries to
defend, then you just take on C three
with checkmate to follow.
And it's this important idea of
clearance, making a move with tempo
and then bringing a rook into
the game. Of course, there's
a million other winning moves, and this is
not a rare theme. This is pretty common.
It's just something to file away into your
mental directory of ideas.
If white tries bishop
C one,     then I think
the winning line is to give a check
and slide the queen over to B three to set
up another Smothered mate with queen D one.
Knight F four was the best move, according
to the engine. Yeah. Yeah. This is minus
eight. Queen takes d three is merely
minus six. So
it wasn't the worst idea in the world to
take on D three. But yes, nite f four is the
most accurate move for sure.   Just to
finish the thought,   after
queen h five, sorry, in the
Gothenburg variation,   uh, the
reason that knight takes E six is no
longer considered a reputation
is because after bishop B
five, there is this very computerish move.
Bobby Fisher actually found this
move, rook h seven.
This move actually allows black to
hold. And according to modern engines, it is
a draw. It's a miserable position
for Black. Black has to play
1000 engine moves in a row, but
somehow Black is able to hold the draw
here.   So, like castles,
I think it goes king Ghee
six. As you can see, this is totally
terrifying. Rook g seven. Rook f
seven.     And then
I think black is supposed to go bishop
takes h four takes,
I mean, some line like this and apparently
black skin survives. But who really wants
to go for this, right? But if you want to
play this like an engine, you're supposed to
play queen h five here rather than knight
takes C six. But anyways, back to the
speedrun game. Not a long game, not a
complicated game, but hopefully a good
illustration of how to play in these
relatively closed center
positions. Patience,   uh, and
deliberate play is very, very important.
Okay,
I think that concludes the
speedrun.    That's probably
enough for this game.
Those of you who are new to my channel, I
have a YouTube channel. We are slowly
moving toward 400K subs.
So every sub counts and
allows me to keep going.
So thank you to everybody who
supports,   uh, in these difficult times.